AND OFF THE ERE THEY WILL GET S
AND NICK R R TIPPED IN FRONT, T
ASIDE BY MARKSTROM ON THE NY OB.
LEADS THE LEAGUE AT ASIDE.
SHOOTS, SCORES!
[ Horn ] THE
GOALTETE
TWO GOALS IN THE FIRST 1:16 OF
THE PERIOD. ZADOROV
STEPS UP, MANGIAPANE WITH GOOD
TIMING  FLAMES ARE COMING IN
WELL TO BE IN THE DEFENSIVE
POSTURE IN THE OFFENSIVE ZONE
THAT CREATES THIS
[ Cheers and Applause ] AND THE
BY DILLON DUBE.
THIS IS WHEN HE'S AT HIS BEST,
TO BE ABLE TO SP COMES OFF THE
ELIAS LINDHOLM SNEAKS ONE OFF
THE POST AND SECOND..N JOSE.
LAST TIME CALGARY DID THAT WAS
MARCH AFTER
COCOLINE.
PUTS IT THROUGH TO MANGIAPANE,
AND THAT'S MIXING THINGS
UP.
S BUT HE
[INDISCERNIBLE] NOT A KICKING
TO THE SAME SPOT, TOP ZONE.
THIS IS A TOUGH ONE FOR SATERI
BECAUSE IT'S SO CLOSE TO HIS
HEAD THAT HE CAN'T GETS BUILDIN.
>> Cassie: 1980S, THAT